Welcome back, everyone it's Charlie
This will be my Full
Last of Us Episode 7 Video.
There were a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references to the game,
so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes
and careful for spoilers of the episode
if you haven't seen it yet.
We'll start at the beginning.
Work our way through, shot by shot,
talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments,
starting with the title left Behind.
It's a reference to the DLC
from the first game that explains Ellie's
backstory.
It's primarily focused on Ellie and Riley,
but just like you saw in the episode,
it jumps back and forth
between the present day
when she's trying to take care of Joel
to keep him from bleeding out
and back in her past.
Primarily, it's focused on the events of
their adventure in the abandoned shopping
mall in the Boston Quarantine zone
and the events of Riley's death
that wound up traumatizing
Ellie even more than she already was.
But the way they end the episode
on the cliffhanger there,
they don't actually show you
what happens to Riley after that.
Like, they end on a bit of a cliffhanger
with her back in present day
trying to fix Joe.
So we don't know if that's the last time
we've ever seen Riley
or if they'll cover the rest of that
in a future episode,
because there's still more flashbacks
that we haven't seen yet
that were in the early trailers.
The actual opening scene picks up in
present day in the snowy suburbs nearby
just after the end of Episode six,
with Ellie having drugged Joel
to an abandoned house.
You can see the horse in there
in the house with her,
which is smart of her to do
because it'll keep the Raiders
that attack them from spotting them,
and it'll keep the horse
from wandering off
while she's dealing with Joel.
But he has lost a ton of blood.
He's on the edge of death.
Like you see him breathing.
They want to let you know that
he's still alive, but he's barely alive.
He tries to get her to leave him behind
and return to Tommy's
settlement in the north.
That's what he whispers her.
Go north to Tommy.
They do plan on going back eventually,
but that was meant to be after
their current mission
of finding the fireflies.
Like Joel did
tell Tommy that he planned to come back
and make a home at his settlement.
And even though they haven't
had that literal conversation yet, like,
what is the future
hold for the two of us together?
Is a relationship.
Like, are we going to live together
in a household
or are we going to make a family together?
When they came back together
at the end of last week's episode,
they kind of implied that they had sort of
to think of each other more closely
and they would probably head
in that direction.
But they haven't
literally said that to each other yet
in the way they edited
this part of the episode,
the way she puts her
hand on the door to leave the room.
If you haven't played the video game
before,
they kind of want you to think
she might actually leave him behind
because the title of the episode
is left Behind.
But as we find, it's
more of a reference to Riley's character.
Really,
though, she's just leaving the room
to look for more supplies
to close his wound,
which he doesn't find
till the end of the episode.
Then they flash back to the events
before episode one.
It's not that long ago,
within a year or so of episode one,
maybe a little bit less than that.
The music track
they pick up on is a super deep cut.
It's Pearl Jam's all for none,
and it's meant to be a metaphor
for Ellie's current life in the Boston
Quarantine zone.
Life is hopeless for her.
Like the lyrics in the song
say it's the apocalypse.
Humanity is fighting a losing battle
and most have given up
and are just wasting away,
just going through the motions.
She has no real prospects other than
becoming part of the fedra system.
The school she's in
is controlled by Phaedra.
It's used as a glorified training program
for new fedra soldiers.
The funny thing
is, Marlene told her in episode one, I'm
the one that put you
in that bedroom school to keep you safe,
not because she wanted her
to become part of Phaedra,
but because she knew
that would be the safest place for her.
But the whole idea with this
fedra school is that they have these
in all the different quarantine zones,
and they use it as a glorified training
program for new fedra soldiers
because their current soldiers
keep dying off
either to fights, accidents or the fungus.
So they need new blood.
They need fresh meat for the grinder,
so to speak.
So any new kids born in the quarantine
zone usually get thrown into the system
or they explain
they wind up becoming bottom feeders,
basically doing these really menial tasks,
really crappy jobs for crappy rations.
Life in general
is meant to be terrible for everyone,
but even more terrible for people
who aren't working for Phaedra.
At this point in the timeline,
Ellie doesn't know she's immune.
That doesn't happen until way later
when they get attacked by the stalker
and she doesn't wind up
turning like a normal person.
And they didn't
even show that in this episode.
So I wonder if there's going to be a part
two to these flashbacks.
We'll see.
At this point, though,
she just thinks she's like every other
normal kid living in the quarantine zone.
The girl who hazes her
during their gym class
for running too slow
isn't supposed to be Abby from the games.
The episode credits her as Bethany,
who's meant to be a random foil for Ellie.
Abby is a huge antagonist,
but it's during the Last of Us 2 game,
so the show will have to introduce her in
season two or season three at some point.
She was the daughter of the lead doctor
of the Fireflies in Salt Lake City, Utah.
During the events of the first game,
which they are doing for season one.
So we'll probably meet him
at the end of season one,
but I'm not expecting to meet Abby
at least until season two.
They might reference her
at the end of the season, though.
There are a bunch of references
to the second game
which they'll cover in season
two during episode six.
So even this early on the show,
they're already referencing stuff
from season two and season three.
Ellie's friend that the girl references
is Riley, obviously who's disappeared
because she's dropped out of the
v school and joined the Fireflies.
But Ellie doesn't learn that until later
when Riley returns
after being gone for a little while.
Her whole thing about fighting back
is meant to show you the anger
that she keeps inside her that starts
to manifest more when she's with Joel.
A really good example of
that is when they first encounter
the hunters in Kansas City.
And she has to save Joel
when she's got her gun on the hunter.
You look at the excitement on her eyes
that flashes for a second
before she gets really scared.
That's her feeding off of the crazy energy
and the violence here.
The showrunner, Neil Druckmann,
talked about this, too.
She's got this violence inside her
that's meant to be kind of
like Joel's violent tendencies,
especially the way Joel was in the past,
the terrible stuff
that Tommy said they did
while they were with the hunters
before arriving in the Boston
Quarantine zone.
So once Ellie left
at the beginning of the season with Joel,
they start running into these dangerous
groups and situations
and things get really violent really fast.
It starts to excite her
more like the two of them.
Ellie and Joel need each other
metaphorically and literally,
because she doesn't quite have the skills
needed to survive a journey across
the United States by herself yet.
She's getting a little bit better.
She got a little bit better.
Last week's episode in Joel, for example,
needs her to help him
survive literally this near fatal wound
or save him from the hunters.
And they also need each other's
emotional support.
Like they show you.
Joel growing as a person,
like becoming more of a person,
so to speak, feeling all the feelings.
So while they have all that positive
father daughter relationship stuff
developing on the negative side of that,
both of them kind of feed off of each
other's violence in a toxic kind of way.
Like just being with Joel
didn't make her more violent.
She already had that in her,
and they kind of
bring that out of each other
a little bit in situations like this.
She gets hold of the fedra office
and the picture of his wife and daughter
remind her of how alone she is.
It's meant to be a metaphor
for the end of the episode
when she thinks that Riley
is going to abandon her.
Remember,
the title of the episode is Left Behind.
It's all about being left behind
or leaving things behind.
The reveal Ellie's been in the hole
at least three times.
Remember, this is the apocalypse.
She's only about 13 years old
when this is happening.
Because you didn't start out with Joel
till she's about 14.
So it's a good picture of just
how bad society has gotten in general,
putting a 13 year old
in solitary confinement prison style.
When he gets real with her
about her future
prospects, it's
either become part of the fedra system,
become an agent, or live a life similar
to one of the randos
that you saw in episode one, like what
Joel was doing, those random jobs.
Now, obviously,
Joel had a lot of stuff going on inside.
He's a smuggler with Tess,
but all the regular jobs that he was
pulling on the side just looked total crap
the way he's trying to sell her on it.
He's basically saying your life could be
slightly less crap or totally crap.
Those are your two options.
How much crap do you actually want?
Wish you could also make a reference
to Riley later in the episode
when she says she literally was given
the job of managing sewage
in the Boston Quarantine.
So like, literally managing
the crap of the Boston Quarantine zone.
He references the fireflies
catching a bullet from one of them.
That's because they're super militant,
which they show you later in the episode
because Riley has been constructing
pipe bombs for them.
They go after fedra all the time,
and you saw that a little bit in episode
one when Marlene was planning on breaking
Ellie out at the beginning of the season.
They plan a massive diversion.
Normally,
they take more guerrilla tactics,
more isolated incidents like blowing up
cars.
You saw where Tess was being held.
They do stuff like that all the time.
They also try to use this conversation
with the fedra agent
to get you to sympathize more with them,
because not all of them
are meant to be total dirtbags.
Like some of them are trying
to hold humanity together.
Although the way Riley tells it,
the agent here,
this agent wanted her on crap detail.
So he is a little bit of a dirtbag.
When he tells Ellie one day she could be
a leader, he sees potential in her.
That's foreshadowing for present day
when she actually does have to take charge
and save Joel.
Also foreshadowing for much later
like beyond the events of the games
when she could potentially become
a bigger leader to the survivors.
We'll see if they make the Last of Us
three game.
Maybe they'll cover some of that
during that game inside her bedroom
while they're panning across the walls,
all of her stuff.
The camera lingers on a baseball bat
that made me think of the infamous
baseball bat from the Last of Us 2.
I won't say more about that
because it gets into huge spoilers.
So if you have played the games,
please don't post spoilers for that
in the comments.
The dinosaur on her wall
is an Easter egg for the dinosaurs.
As Joel shows Ellie
in a museum that they pass through,
which is also in the second game.
And there are several more mentions
of dinosaurs.
Later in the episode too,
we see her Will Livingston Book of Puns,
but it's Volume one,
not the one that she has later.
That's volume two, and it's given to her
by Riley as a gift later, which we saw
in the future in previous episodes
when she's reading to Joel.
The camera also lingers
on her pocketknife, which she winds up
using later to kill the stalker
at the end of the episode.
Like, this is going to come in real handy
real soon.
She's reading one of her Savage
Starlight comic books,
which they've referenced several times
in the Henry and Sam episode.
R.I.P.
The actual plot of the Savage
Starlight Comics are usually meant
to be metaphors
for Ellie and Joel's adventures.
But in this context, for this episode,
it's more of a metaphor for Ellie
and Riley's adventure together,
because she hasn't met Joel yet.
And in the comic book issue, they talk
about breaking into this secret area.
That's what they do in the episode,
breaking in to the abandoned mall.
There are a couple of movie posters
on her wall.
There's a Red Planet movie poster
and one for the Lunar Phases of the Moon,
which is a reference to her wish
to travel to the moon, become an astronaut
someday, like her hero, Sally Ride,
which she just told the joke.
The poster behind her is for Innerspace,
which is about a group of characters
shrinking down Ant-Man, Dalek.
Like we just got Ant-Man, the WASP
Quantumania in the movie theaters.
Inside that movie,
they do something similar.
They shrink down to go into someone's
body to save them,
which is also meant to be a reference
to her immunity.
Her condition
in saving Joel's life in present day.
You also remember that
culture in the world froze in 2003
so there wouldn't be any movie posters
or pop culture from after that.
The empty bed used to be Riley's before
she dropped out and joined the Fireflies.
She's got a couple old cassette
tapes for her Walkman, AHA's
Greatest Hits,
which they play later in the episode.
Also, the Etta James tape.
I can't see the name of the middle one,
but the Etta James is also from
The Last of Us Left Behind DLC Game too.
Most of the episode is pretty close
to what they did in the games.
They even have the Mortal Kombat
two poster, which is a big video game
reference and an Easter egg
that they pay off later in the episode
and earlier in the season, when she sees
different versions of the mortal Combat
two Arcade machine, the actual poster
is meant to belong to Riley.
She's the person
who was the huge Mortal Kombat.
Stan, I believe Mortal Kombat
made it into the video games
because the people
who made the video games at Naughty Dog
were just fans of the Mortal Kombat games,
then playing the Mortal Kombat
two arcade machine later in the episode at
the Arcade is also taken directly
from that part of the video game.
There's a couple more pictures of rocket
ships meant to be more references
to astronauts and going to outer space.
Then we actually meet Riley
when she returns.
Played by storm Reed, who you probably
recognize from a bunch of other stuff.
She explains how she joined the fireflies.
At this point, Ellie doesn't really know
Marlene or the fireflies yet, but
like I said, Marlene
definitely knows Ellie right now.
Ellie really only knows
what other people say about the fireflies.
Generally, they distrust them
because they're so violent.
They do all these crazy things
all over the Boston Quarantine zone.
So she doesn't take them that seriously
as they leave to go to the abandoned mall.
You see the paleontology
book near them, too, on her nightstand.
That's meant to be another one of the many
dinosaur references in the episode.
And previously in the season,
the 7-Eleven eyebrow joke
that they make in
the alleyway is probably a reference
to an earlier fight
that they had at some point at a 7-Eleven
where one of them lost an eyebrow.
They make it sound like
they get in a bunch of fights.
Riley's
whole speech about picking and choosing
what's important to fight for,
not trying to fight for
everything
is all about the Firefly missions
that she's now taken upon herself,
focusing their aggression all their time
on the Firefly specific missions,
the carol that they mentioned
that Riley formerly put in the hospital
isn't meant to be someone from the games.
She's just someone that really beat
the crap out of in the past.
They find the dead guy with the booze
and the pills.
Probably bad idea
to get so close to dead people.
Some of you may picked up on this though.
The super rare booze from before.
The fungus in the pills
are meant to be a reference to Joel
because he would have gotten
those from Joel, especially the pills.
That's what we saw him
selling to the guard in episode one.
Joel intense his primary thing
before he met Ellie.
We're being smugglers trading in stuff
like this, then drinking from the bottle
also meant to be a reference to her
asking for Joel's flask.
The whole moment here,
especially with the dead
body, reminded me a lot of stand By Me.
Like, do you want to see a dead body?
Ellie bothers Riley for her gun
a bunch of times,
the same way that she bothers
Joel in present day for a gun
until she eventually proves
herself worthy.
When Riley is explaining
how she met Marlene,
the joke about her being super old like,
I don't know.
She's some super old person.
40 or 50 is a reference to the games
because Merle Dandridge, the actress
who plays Marlene on the show, is the same
person who plays Marlene in the games.
And the original game was published
about ten years ago.
She's about ten years
older now, almost in her fifties.
The actress even joked about
how she'd aged into the proper age
for playing Marlene.
Like in the game,
Marlene is supposed to be about that age,
but when she played her in the video game
originally, she was way younger.
Later,
Riley explains how Marlene recruited her,
like she saw how she hated
fedra, and Riley left
because she would be given
the literal crap detail.
Like it wasn't even a metaphor.
She was literally supposed to be
watching sewage for the rest of her life.
You get to pick the fireflies
or watching crap for the rest of time.
Hmm. Pretty hard choice to make there
when they enter the abandoned mall.
This is all right. Out of the video game.
They start down the escalators.
It's meant to be Ellie's
first time experience seeing an escalator,
which is why her mind is so blown.
They also start playing that aha song,
which is a reference back to the aha
tape that she has.
She also plays that song on her guitar
during The Last of Us to game.
Most of the songs that they use
in the show
and the covers that they use are meant
to be taken directly from the video games.
There's another huge video
game, Easter Egg, super deep cut here
on the movie posters
in the theater marquee.
The Dawn of the Wolf movies
are part of the video games.
Joel talks about watching them with
his daughter when she was still alive.
Also, the plot is meant to be similar
to the plot of the games.
The protagonists are meant to be metaphors
for Joel and Ellie.
Ellie, joking about the lingerie
from Victoria's Secret with Riley
is meant to be a reference
to their relationship,
but they kind of pay off
at the end of the episode before things go
completely to crap, so to speak,
as they both get attacked by the stalker.
Everything with the carousel was also
a huge part of the video game to her mind.
Also blown by it because she's never been
on a carousel before.
The tune that was playing
while they were riding around
sounded a little bit
like another cover of that same aha song
all the rabbit mentions,
and the rabbit pictures in the photo
booth are meant to be references
for the rabbit from the game The L.A.
kills while hunting for herself and Joel
while he's recovering from his wounds.
There was also a reference
in last week's episode to the Rabbit meme,
which is also based on that same moment
in the games.
The fourth wonder Riley takes her to
is the video game arcade.
And this is also right
out of the game where they play
the Mortal Kombat two arcade machine.
The whole joke about the paper money
when she's looking for coins to use
in the arcade machines is because paper
money is essentially worthless
in the apocalypse.
That's why it's lying around like it's
nothing like Monopoly money.
There was also a subtle reference
to this back
during episode three
when Bill mentioned something similar,
like how much something was worth
and he said, Currently it's worth
nothing because there is no real economy
like there used to be.
The actual economy around the world.
Post fungus is mostly a bartering
and trade based economy,
where people just trade important things
like medicine, food for other things.
Riley admits to spending about an hour
the previous day breaking the coin machine
so that they could actually
play the games later.
She also admits to living in this area
and being posted here by Marlene
as part of their Firefly missions.
So she's actually been staying here
for a while, getting better and better
at the Mortal Kombat two game, which is
why she's so much better than Ellie.
And this is basically the first time
that Ellie's probably played a video game
or even seen one.
They do still have video games, movies,
television shows on Blu
ray, DVD,
things like that in the apocalypse.
Like Tommy said in last week's episode,
we're getting ready to watch a movie
and they watch the Goodbye Girl issues
that nobody is making new games,
new movies, new TV shows.
It's all old stuff.
Also,
probably not a lot of TVs, home video game
consoles
lying around the quarantine zones.
If you've never played mortal combat,
the Deadpool isn't meant to be a reference
to Marvel's Deadpool.
It's just the name of the room
that the characters
are actually fighting in nearby.
In another store,
a stalker wakes up when it hears
the noise that they're making.
Stalkers
are the second stage of the infection.
They're a little more powerful than
runners, but not quite as bad as clickers.
Then Riley gives her her gift,
which is the second book of puns that
she's been reading in present day to Joel,
the cannibal puns that she mentions.
First, also kind of a reference to what
probably wind up happening in next week's
episode, Episode eight, where we'll see
a confirmed Troy Baker cameo.
He's playing
one of the cannibals from the games,
which Ellie winds up running into
in present day one.
She's trying to nurse Joel back to health
and look for food.
I love that.
They don't know what screenshots are
because they've never used computers.
Remember, both of them
grew up after the fungus hit in 2003.
So they're all kinds of stuff
that they've never experienced or seen.
Ellie finds the pipe bombs
that Riley has been making
as part of her missions for the Fireflies,
she reveals.
Marlene posted her here.
It's all part of their day
to day for fighting Phaedra and reveals
that Marlene is sending her
to the Atlanta quarantine zone.
But Marlene said that she couldn't
take Ellie with her.
So tonight's
supposed to be her last night in Boston.
And this is like a last hurrah.
She's saying goodbye to her
even though we know she doesn't wind up
going to Atlanta because she
essentially says, okay, fine, I'll stay.
Which makes it sound like Riley plan
to leave the fireflies to be
with Ellie, which is why the ending is
meant to be so tragic for the two of them.
We almost had it all.
Then the stalker came to get us.
Riley explained that she thought the
fireflies could be like her new family.
And unlike Ellie,
she actually remembers what it was like
having a family like a mother
and a father.
Ellie's mother died
when she was extremely young,
which is also another big
cameo from the video games.
She's going to be played by Ashley
Johnson, who voiced Ellie in the video
games.
We've seen her in the trailers,
so they'll have to show her either
in episode eight or Episode nine,
because they're only nine
episodes in season one
when they start dancing,
she gives her The Wolfman mask.
That's meant to be another reference
to the Dawn of the Wolf movies.
In the games, in the song that Riley plays
is meant to be from the Etta James tape
that Ellie has.
It's the Etta James version of
I've Got You Babe,
which is also from
The Last of Us Left Behind DLC.
Like they use the same song in the video
game.
Most people remember the song
from the Sonny and Cher version.
They did the original version.
The song Etta James covered it.
Later, they kiss
but then get attacked by the stalker
with both of them being infected
after Ellie eventually kills them.
That's why Riley flipped a little.
She sees the Ellie has been bitten,
and then Ellie sees the same thing
that Riley's been bitten, too.
At least at this point,
Ellie doesn't know she's immune.
Riley doesn't know that she's immune
either.
They both think that they're
definitely going to die.
The debate
on whether or not they kill themselves
before the infection can take them.
Ellie is the one that wants them
to shoot themselves.
Riley gives them this big call
to action, though, about never giving up,
no matter what
it's meant to be a version of the speech
she gives her in the game.
Pretty much all their major scenes
together, all the speeches, the dialog
they have are taken directly
from the game in million ways.
We should have done it before today
and a million ways
we can die before tomorrow.
But we fight
for every second we get to spend
with each other, but we don't quit.
It's 2 minutes
or two days.
We don't get that which is meant to inform
some of her behavior in the future
and the end of the episode
when she doesn't give up on Joel.
They've already implied
that Riley is dead in present day
and something terrible winds up
happening to her.
But they don't show you in this episode,
so I don't know if they plan
on doing that later in the season
or if this is all we're getting.
For Riley flashbacks.
But they end the episode
back in present day with Ellie finding,
threading the needle to close Joel's
wound, and then they pay to the credits
in Essentially, the title Left Behind is
meant to be a reference to Ellie having to
leave her childhood behind, so to speak,
like she has to grow up real fast.
But she also had to leave her
closest friend Riley behind, too,
and she's not leaving. Joel behind.
So a lot of people and things
being left behind
and not left behind during the episode
overall was a pretty solid episode.
There's still a bunch of plot
that they have to cover.
Like I said, there's only nine
episodes in the season.
What'll happen is my Episode
eight trailer video will post tomorrow
and then my full Episode eight video
will post next week after they release it.
And big reminder
Pedro Pascal into the Pascal verse,
The Mandalorian Season 3 episodes
starring Pedro Pascal Start this Week
My Full Mandalorian Season three Episode
one video will post on Wednesday
after they release that if you spotted
any other Easter eggs or references
in the episode
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
Everyone click here for my Last of Us
Episode eight Video Edit the link
as soon as I post that and click here
for my Mandalorian Season three Episode 1
Video. Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.